gobbler welcome to the show Tim it's a
great pleasure to be here thank you I
have been looking forward to this
conversation for a really long time and
I wanted to make an attempt at least to
do it right so I wanted to have the
video and the audio and everything else
because I think the work you're doing is
very important and we're going to cover
a lot of ground which I'm very excited
to cover because I think it's a real
contribution and you have tools and
frameworks can really help people I
thought we might start with ebooks and
the reason I thought that could be a fun
place to start my audience loves books
number one but number two in tribal
mentors the last book that I wrote or
that my guests wrote you were featured
and I thought that many of the books you
mentioned paint a picture of your life
experience and also your life's work in
many ways and we can go in any
particular order but I thought maybe it
would make sense to start with the
scourge of the swastika and that was one
that you mentioned had had an impact on
you or that perhaps you recommended on
occasion why is that well so this has to
do with my family's history I grew up
was born in Budapest Hungary in 1944 in
January two months before the Germans
occupied the country and hungry at that
time was the only country in Eastern
Europe where the Jewish population had
not been annihilated and now it was our
turn so I was two months of age the day
after the German army marched into
Budapest my mother phoned the
pediatrician to say would you please
come and see gob oh of course he's
crying all the time and the pediatrician
said of course I will come but I should
tell you all my Jewish days of her
crying and of course that's the infant's
picking up on her mother's terror and
stress and that's how I spent the first
year of my life which is had a huge
impact on my development and my lifelong
struggles with depression and ADHD self
Shayne and I know other issues jumping
ahead now I knew very little about that
history
my parents didn't say much about it as I
was growing up I knew my grandparents
had been killed in Auschwitz
I knew my father had been in forced
labor and I never saw him for a year and
a half but beyond that I knew not much
about the details until I was about nine
or 10 maybe 11 years old and it was a
book on my parents shelf in Budapest
with the title the scourge of the
swastika wishes were written by a
British civil servant and a member of
the House of Lords this man had served
at the British Army and he was the first
book published in the 50s that detailed
the Nazi crimes and I climbed up on a
chair took down the book when I was I
think 10 or 11 began to read it saw
photographs of the horrors of the
concentration camps and the
extermination details in Eastern Europe
and all of a sudden I swooned because I
got what happened to my family and that
question of how can people do such
things to other human beings which
strike me every day and in almost every
day this thought occurred to me for
years and years and years almost every
day I almost got dizzy with the question
so why people suffer and my people make
other people suffer and what is the
original all that has been a motivating
question in my life so that's why that
book was so important to me thank you
and and I have to say that you know my
life's work has been motivated by that
question as a medical doctor
I'm always looking at what is it that
makes people be the way they are why do
we come cruel why to become victims why
do we become perpetrators what drives us
what kind of insanity covers our basic
human nature which I believe to be good
and and and positive and what happens to
us
we're gonna spend a lot of time in that
territory for sure okay Cement insanity
or insanity I'm not sure if that's a
good segue to Don Quixote but I'll let
you choose the next one so there are a
few that came up and you described them
in brief in the pages of the book but
for instance the background you just
gave me it was much more in-depth so we
have a few and these are gonna strike
folks as eclectic we need the puh the
Dhammapada the drama of the gifted child
and Don Quixote which one of those would
you like to explain next Chloe the bend
of the pool let's go with Winnie the
Pooh yeah so that was one of the seminal
books of my childhood and my parents
would have read to me long before I even
knew how to read the Hungarian title is
mitzi mud school and it was finally
Moscow Mitzi Mitsuko Mitzi the bear and
the translator is the great hunger and
humorist
so if anything the Hungarian book is
even funnier than the original English
which is not something one usually says
about translations but what's talking
about pool of course was number one that
there was this bear of little brains who
was some of so much wiser than everybody
else so fundamental he found the piece
inside despite the fact that his
intellect is just under functioning
number one number two there was this
relationship with the little boy
Christopher Robin and there's a passage
towards the end of the book where
Christopher Robin I don't even know the
real story in fact there's a movie
there's a movie about it right now but
but Christopher Robin
his father a EML was a writer and he
bought these toys for his son to make
stories about them and Christopher Robin
actually suffered because he was
secondary to his father's career they
did not have a good relationship so
these characters that the father Mia
made up kind of dominated and squeezed
out Christopher Robin's own life and
himself became a bookseller later in his
life and he wrote about his
autobiography
so there's something about the
dysfunctionality and father-son
relationship but in the book
Christopher is playing with his toys and
then he starts to grow up and he has to
go to school and he won't be able to
play with his toys anymore and at the
very end of the book there's a passage
where the book ends with but wherever
they go in the enchanted forest
the little boy as bear will always be
playing together and that would just
bring tears to my eyes
for decades upon decades upon decades
until recently I had a an experience
actually a psychedelic experience when I
realized that there's nothing to mourn
because I'm both the bear and the little
boy and I was will be playing that
nothing is lost but when I read that
book there was a sense of loss when I
read that passage was always something's
being lost childhood innocence is being
lost playfulness is being lost which
resonated with my own shot because I did
lose innocence and and then playfulness
very early in life so both for the fun
and the humor then of course dizzy or
for whom everything always goes badly
and it's a part of me that's totally or
always expecting the worst and nothing
will ever work out for me and never mind
leave me alone I'm okay in my own
suffering you know that that's sort of
determined victim attitude that was also
very much too germane to my inner
experience so that book just spoke to me
and made me laugh and it still does it's
one of the funniest books ever written
and one of the wisest as well I need to
I've only I am ashamed to say this but
I've only seen the cartoon oh right I
know I know but listen listen one of the
sins that Walt Disney is gonna be
burning in hell for the rest of
existence is what he did with those the
stories as he Disney fight them I didn't
find them you you you got to read the
original do ya and and you you would
laugh your head off guard
amen amen I wish I spoke Hungarian so I
could read the translation which of
these would you like to and we can
certainly touch on other books but so we
have three three remaining on my list
the Dhammapada the drama of the gifted
child and Don Quixote
well let's go to the drama of the gifted
child into the drum of the gifted child
is by a Swiss German Jewish Swiss
psychotherapist named Alice Miller who
was for three decades a psychoanalyst
but she realized that the Freudian
psychical psychoanalytic method wasn't
helping anybody get better because it
ignored trauma so the drama of the
gifted child the German title of which
was prisoners of childhood was really
all about the fact that stuff happens to
us as children negative things happen
then we adapted those things by taking
on certain defensive ways of being and
then we leave the rest of our lives from
those defensive modes so we're not
actually experiencing the present but
constantly reliving the past from a
perspective that we acquired when we
were helpless and vulnerable children
and when she says the gifted shot she
means a sensitive child so the more
sensitive the child is the more he or
she feels the pain and stress of the
environment and the more affected they
are and the more that shapes their lives
and that book came along for me when I
was in my 40s and I was a successful
doctor and and and and and I was a
father but I was depressed I was anxious
I was a driven workaholic you wouldn't
have known that when you saw me on the
job but inside me I was discouraged I
had difficulties in my marriage with my
children I felt they were afraid of me
and they were because of my rages and
that book helped me understand it was
the first book to help me understand
where all that came from so that was for
me as for many of the people a seminal
read and really my whole work since then
has been to help liberate people from
that prison the childhood often imposes
on so many of us this book has come up
repeatedly in my life as a
recommendation as a recommended YA book
from friends who benefited from it they
are very certainly from any outward
perspective highly functioning yeah
in some cases world-class performers in
their fields and I'm in retrospect sad
that I ignored those recommendations but
it was in part because I didn't like the
pairing of gifted child I didn't want to
label myself given child we could
certainly psychoanalyze that but I was
like hmm if this is a book written for
people who are in say gifted and
talented programs or have some god-given
talent for whatever reason I had
resistance to that so I didn't read it
but the prisoners of childhood makes a
lot more sense to me anyway well I think
it's a more accurate title but there's
two things I would say in response first
of all why do you resist your own
giftedness you're clearly gifted so why
would you not want to find out about
that don't know yeah so that's that's
something you might want to consider
sure number one number two really what
she means is the sensitive child yeah so
sensitive yeah I that would draw me in
because I've had we don't have to
necessarily go down this rabbit hole
right now but I've had a number of my
friends recently asked me when did you
know you were so sensitive yeah and not
sensitive in a in a hyper reactive way
not in a negative way just in a
perceptive way and I'd never thought of
myself it would never have occurred to
me to label myself sensitive and just in
the last year I've been thinking about
that so this the sensitive child would
make make more more sensor be more
appealing well yeah you have to think of
sensitive in terms of its word origin
the word sensitive came so in the Latin
word sense here to feel so the sensitive
person feels more yeah so the example I
often give is and enacting lead to both
very positive and very difficult
consequences for example if I tapped you
on the shoulder right now you wouldn't
feel any pain at all but if you're not
wearing a shirt and and your skin was
exposed
furthermore if you're a burn on your
shoulder so your nerve endings were
close to the surface if I attack you
with the same force you'd feel extreme
excruciating pain even though the
external event was no different right so
sensitivity magnifies the pain that we
have
sensitivity also leads to more
creativity so very often the most
creative people also have the most pain
which is my so many creative people
escape from their pain through all kinds
of dysfunctions like addictions and so
on so there's a real link between
creativity and sensitivity and create
the video and and sensitivity and
suffering at the same time that's the
first point that would make no the other
thing goes back to what you said about
these people that you know of or high
performers look at that word performers
what does it mean to perform one meaning
of it is to put on a show sure that's
one meaning and I would have been one of
these people who was a high performer in
other words look that's from the outside
a successful funny doctor director of a
palliative care unit at a major hospital
national columnist for Canadian
newspaper writing medical columns
performing at a high level and inside
again anxious frustrated depressed
discouraged and in my personal life a
lot of suffering so a lot of people who
perform well are actually deeply
troubled inside and of course there's
many famous examples of that some of the
greatest performers like Presley or
melon Munroe and any number of people
like a name that's what they were they
were performers and even from themselves
they hid their own suffering well we are
sitting in a venue right now recording
this that is is now known as lzr and
there is a mural of prints outside
because he performed his as I understand
at last performance in this venue really
before he passed away before he
overdosed before he overdosed yeah
exactly and we can certainly come back
to this but part of the reason I wanted
to big piece of the reason I wanted to
have you on this show was that I spent
I'm in a much better place now for many
reasons that maybe outside of this
interview but feeling the exact same way
you just described yeah
outwardly successful inwardly tortured
yeah and
how do you answer the question if
someone meets you and you just have a
short interaction what do you do what do
I do if someone asks you yeah what do
you do
I may be self-serving but some people
once called me up people whisper people
whisper I I do have a gift for seeing
inside because I've studied I'm also
sensitive and in some ways and I've also
studied myself very deeply I've had to
because my life just wasn't working and
as a medical doctor I've worked with all
manner of conditions terminal diseases
newborns families physical illnesses
mental dysfunctions I spent 12 years
working with addictions I spent on
exploring my own and other people's ADHD
and so I work with people to bring out
the truth of their experience so that
they're no longer prisoners of their
childhood but that they can make a
conscious choice about how to live in
the present moment not based on how they
were programmed and charted and but for
that you have to do it in a way that the
dog whisperer do in a very compassionate
way otherwise people just shut down and
and and they they shrivel up and they
protect themselves so that's what I do
and I know I also write and I speak
publicly and so on but the intent is
always to bring insight and liberation
to people so I'm going to come back to
the medicine because I'd love to know
when your journey into medicine began
but first since I know my listeners will
say but you forgot the other two books
the other talks the Dhammapada Don
Quixote in any order you like
well let's go in the order that I
discovered them which is Don Quixote
which again I read that as a child and
then reread many times as an adult and
he's my favorite character so Quixote is
this deluded Spanish small nobleman who
wants to revive the age of chivalry and
chivalric knighthood
so he guessed his broken-down horse
called Rocinante and he is Lance and his
sword and his he gets this Squire called
Sancho Panza on his donkey and off they
go to these adventures and he does not
see reality
he thinks windmills are Giants and he
attacks them and of course he gets hurt
and he keeps getting hurt because
because he doesn't see reality he but
his heart is purely committed to
liberating people to truth to justice to
to fighting oppressors to liberating the
oppressed so here's this guy who really
wants to do good in the world
and he's just deluded in his vision but
he's far truer and deeper and more human
than all the people that scoff at him
and laugh at him so what a great
character and the book is both poignant
and very funny and it's he's one of the
great creations of world literature and
of course again you know that yearning
for justice has always burned in my
heart
owing to what happened to me and what I
witnessed in the Dhammapada the demo
part is the Buddha's collection of
sayings and it begins with basically the
idea that we create the world with our
minds he says everything is thought in
the lead so how we see the world is how
it determines the world that we live in
so if I see the world as a horrible
place according the current president
the United States then I will be
defensive and aggrandizing and selfish
because I want to take before they take
from me I want to attack before I get
attacked
I'll also be too looking out for myself
because the world is not to be trusted
so if that's the world you live in
that's the way you're gonna create and
the Buddha was great psychologist
immature recognize that our perceptions
shaped the world that we live in now
what he didn't say and that's where
modern psychology comes in is that
before with our mind we create the world
the world creates our minds mm-hmm so
that the kind of world that we live in
is very much shaped by early experiences
Buddha didn't say that but into
certainly enough when you think about
his search for truth what happened to
him if you read his biography his mother
died before he was a week old so he's
lost his most important relationship so
his life began with suffering and then
he spent all his life trying to find a
nature of suffering and how to transcend
suffering and how to get beyond it and
this is how he ended up with this
particular method of meditation and
contemplation and truth seeking so that
book was written twenty twenty five
hundred years ago and psychologically we
still catch it trying to catch up to the
wisdom in it so let's talk about wisdom
or perhaps science first yeah and maybe
they're related in some fashion although
I know we'll dig into
certainly some things that might be
missing when did medicine enter your
life for an interest in medicine
interest in being a doctor either of
those things
well I've speculated on that and there's
a number of sources strangely enough or
not so strange enough my grandfather who
was killed in Auschwitz in his 50s
happened to be a writer and a doctor
grandson ends up as a writer and a
doctor so I think part of it was me
trying to fill a hole in my mother's
life that was a devastating blow to her
this is not conscious but I'm
speculating looking back it's not that
she ever said you have to become a
doctor it's not that she ever said you
have to follow in your grandfather's
footsteps but I think I consciously I
stepped into that role number one number
two another reason is that as a Jew in
Eastern Europe you had every reason to
feel insecure and my mother never failed
to tell me that as a doctor you carry
your profession in your hands so you
don't have to have a business you don't
have to have riches you just have to
have the knowledge and then you can go
anywhere in the world and you'll be okay
beyond that healing and and and and and
making this world a better place and
he'll have people help people lead
healthy lives was just an ideal of mine
then there was like a testicle reasons
that say said doctors get respect they
revolve they have a good income people
look up to them and they have a sense of
authority that I think I lacked in my
own life so it was a combination of
unconscious reasons and and and and
idealistic reasons and legatus typical
reasons but but all I know is that all
my life I had wanted to be nothing else
for the doctor I always grew up knowing
I'll be a physician and when you were
studying medicine what did you think
your specialty or specialties might be
well first of all I should say I didn't
end up following the dream because uh I
in my late teens I just couldn't
concentrate and study hard enough to get
through the sciences I could get through
them but I couldn't get the high marks
needed to get to medical school so I
actually taught high school for three
years I taught English and history for
three years and then I would wake up and
and this voice in me you could be a
doctor you gotta be a doctor and so that
I went back to medical school and a lot
of hard work already having been an
older student in medical school and
being interested in history and
literature and a larger picture I always
wanted to put medicine in the context of
history and the context of society in
the context of human experience not just
as an isolated science but as part of
the broader human experience and I was
interested right away from the in the
beginning between in the connections
between emotions and illness between
social factors and and health and so on
so I was always a larger picture person
and so that is that was with me already
in medical school so the integration of
mind and body as opposed to these
Cartesian duality and separation of mind
and body
exactly not that anything in medical
school prepared me for that I mean in
medical school users don't get that
information at all
but that was always my interest and then
when I started practicing if your eyes
are at all open you just can't you can't
help but to see it that who gets sick
and who doesn't is an accidental and who
gets cancer who gets doesn't isn't
accidental and who gets addicted and who
doesn't isn't accidental no there was
this reasons and those reasons go beyond
individual and it has to do with their
emotional lives and their relationships
and a society in the culture that they
live in so more and more over the
decades my own personal struggles and my
medical experience showed me that these
connections are important how did you
end up in palliative care and I suppose
for those people listen you don't know
what palliative care is perhaps you
could give just a brief explanation of
what that is some people might think of
it as hospice care which which I'm not I
don't think are necessarily identical
but well how did you end up what was the
road to palliative care and what is
palliative care so I was a family
physician and a very driven one and also
have a GED which means that you want to
move around and have different
experiences you know because you get
tired of the same thing and really in
retrospect I might say that there's some
guidance in all this but how it occurred
was a series of accidents
so I've happened to be walking down the
hall of Vancouver's major hospital when
the current director of palliative care
said I'm quitting how would you like to
come and work in palliative care and I
said sure you know I didn't think it
took me I'm not a moment to think about
it he was just looking for someone to
grab sure thank you what is that and
deeply meaning for a work because when
people are facing death they also call
come up against the truth of their lives
and and and if you can face death
you can face life impaler difficulty
with the transition with terminal
illness these are people with video from
nothing curative or healing is going to
happen in the sense of physical healing
so they need to be helped with their
symptoms with their pain or
ability or weakness or nausea but also
you have to help them go through the
psychological process of adjusting to a
very short future and the people who get
drawn to palliative care work the nurses
and the doctors tend to be a special
breed it's not because many doctors are
not comfortable with death they're not
comfortable with not being able to do
something to save somebody so you have
to develop a lot of patience and a lot
of acceptance you have to let go of your
power to change things
so it's deeply meaningful and deeply
transformative work and you also have to
work with a lot of people with multiple
different attitudes towards life and
there's religious non-religious
spiritual non-spiritual in denial in
acceptance in all the stages in between
so it was beautiful beautiful work and I
am highlights of my my medical career
all the same time I was still doing my
family practice in when did when did a
focus on addiction or an a an acute
interest in addiction start to steer
your medical practice so I was a family
physician I've always had substantive
iyx in my practice it's just a few and
again it was an accident I got fired
from a palliative care job and my my
argument is that I was fired for gross
competence just too damn good but also
for gross arrogance in other words with
my spontaneous and insightful and rather
radical non-traditional style I could
have great results and often did in
palliative care if I may interrupt for
one second what would be or might be an
example of
your approach that others thought was
radical or something you would say or
something you would do with a patient
that's that that got great results but
that would seem very radical to others
well I would engage them in deep
conversations stuff would come up with
I'll be painful but would be
transformative physically I would just
use methods that have not been proven
but accorded the right to me and they've
seemed to be helpful and helping people
out of pain or deal with issues and so
on I was very open and and multiple
approaches I wasn't just following
things by the book so that was my
competence the arrogance was that I had
a very busy life I was still delivering
babies running my family practice so I
would get into palliative care and then
the nurses said working with me was like
working in the eye of a tornado and
other physicians who didn't have my
attitude or my particular mindset would
legitimately question what I was doing
but I would regard all such questioning
as an attack rather than as an inquiry
and I would react like a bulldog who's
being threatened and that's the
arrogance and that's what ended up
letting me be fired and and it was a
great firing because as always I learned
a lot about myself took me a while but
it took and then three weeks after I was
fired I got this phone call from from
our clinic in Vancouver's Downtown
Eastside now the downtown east side of
Vancouver is North America's most
concentrated area of drug use we have
more injection users in this few scrub
book radius than anywhere in North
America so I get this call saying how
would you like to come and work down
here and this is three weeks after fired
from platter of care had I not been
fired I couldn't have taken that other
job
which then led me to the high point for
my career which is working twelve years
with addicted population and eventually
leaving family practice and doing that
full-time so who orchestrated all this I
have no idea but it was a beautiful
progression something that's come up
quite a bit in interviews on this
podcast is some variation of sometimes
you need life to save you from what you
want to give you what you need exactly
and
I think about that a lot at the very
least it's a it's a pain relieving lens
through which to view events that unfold
how how do you define addiction or maybe
a better question is what is addiction
and and along with that if you want to
tackle it you know what are poor
definitions of addiction or
misconceptions fair enough so an
addiction is a complex psychological
physiological process but which
manifests in any behavior any behavior
that a person enjoys that a person
enjoys finds relief in and therefore
craves in a short-term but suffers
negative consequences in the long term
and doesn't give up despite the negative
consequences so craving pleasure relief
in the short term negative consequences
in the long term inability to give it up
no notice I has said nothing about
substances I said any behavior so it
could be related to cocaine crystal meth
heroin fentanyl marijuana nicotine
alcohol whatever could also be sex
gambling internet relationships shopping
were eating work extreme sports working
out for nog Rafi any number of human
activities so I said any behavior now
the official definition of addiction
according to the American Society for
addiction medicine is that this is
primarily a blink it's a primary brain
disorder
it arises in the brain role largely due
to genetic reasons this is how they see
it and I say that's just not true the
other popular idea what addiction is
that it's a choice that somebody makes
that people choose to be addicted which
is what the legal system is based on
because if people are not choosing what
are we punishing them for and and so I
although I think the medical definition
is closer to the truth I don't see it as
genetic it's a genetic disorder and I
don't see it as a primary brain disorder
so let me perhaps show you why if that's
okay so I give you this definition of
addiction again craving relief pleasure
shorter
negative cost of my long-term inability
to give it up would you be willing to
tell me if you've ever done an addiction
in your life I don't care what - what
I'm not asking what oh yeah oh I can I
can say yes and I can tell you exactly
what it was okay all I in high school so
I saw I suffered for from that's what I
suppose most people would consider
depressive periods beginning at latest
age 10 right and never found relief from
that until I was competing in wrestling
very seriously in high school all
throughout high school and an older
teammate introduced me to a federal so
stimulant a federal hydrochloride which
for those people who are curious is well
at least at one point ephedrine was
found at were at the very least
pseudoephedrine in something called
primatene mist used for asthma right and
I think they also mix it with
guaifenesin nonetheless the reason you
cannot buy in many places large amounts
of primatene mist is because people free
based it into methamphetamine yes right
so you have a federal which is a very
strong stimulant combined with caffeine
and aspirin and we have combined those
three it's not an incremental increase
in effect it's I mean it's probably
logarithmic it's a very synergistic
effect exponentially herbs exactly and
he was recommending it for increased
endurance and there there is some effect
although it's also very highly
thermogenic which wasn't good for me so
made me really hot which was already a
weakness of mine but it ended up
providing me with relief it was a very
strong stimulant and I began to not only
use it for sports but self-medicate
using it okay so great so let me quickly
ask you what did it do for you relief
from what uh it's it's it made me or at
least contributed to euphoria optimism
energy so I didn't I didn't
didn't feel these symptoms of what I in
retrospect I would call depression the
lethargy the pessimistic lens through
which I viewed things fair enough it
seemed to magically just erase all of
that in about 30 minutes
so you folio literally means a good
feeling you gave you energy it gave you
make you feel good it made you
optimistic also improved sports
performance my mom sure did yeah all
those good things are bad things to feel
optimistic those are all good things
okay in other words the addiction wasn't
your primary problem your primary
problem is that you're depressed right
like you lacked a sense of well-being
that you lacked energy right so in other
words the addiction is not the primary
problem it's an attempt to solve a
problem right and then the real question
is how did the problem arise right in
other words this is where my theory is
that it's always rooted in childhood
trauma and that the addiction is an
attempt to deal with the effects of
childhood trauma which it does
temporarily while it creates even more
problems in a long-term right I would
have one more side question for you
given that statement with your drug of
choice this may not be true for you but
do you think retrospect you might have
ADHD is a kid quite possibly because
typically people with ADHD self-medicate
with stimulants yeah because hardly
treat ADHD now we give people stimulants
yeah so so a lot of people that choose
stimulants of self-medication like
nicotine and caffeine and crystal meth
and a third man are actually
self-medicating IDIA suits very likely
yeah and I was punished by teachers for
I wouldn't say not paying attention but
being interested in other things in
class so I remember very distinctly my
kindergarten teacher I'll name her by
name because it's shameful mrs. MS Bevin
or mrs. Bevan hmm I refuse to learn the
alphabet because she wouldn't give me a
good reason why I needed to learn the
alphabet it was just you need to learn
the alphabet so she made me eat soap in
front of the class and put me at the bad
table she got was that too but I was
always interested in doing many many
many things and in fact the reason one
of the reasons that I started wrestling
is because I was very hyperactive and as
I believe the story goes
other mothers recommend it to my mom
that she put me into something called
kiddie wrestling to drain my batteries
before I got home mm-hmm so that makes
perfect sense I've never been drawn to
depressants
we've never been drawn to opiates in
fact after surgeries I get very sick if
I'm given vicodin or anything like that
so I've opted out and have never
personally had any issues with alcohol
although a lot of people do it's always
been a drought of stimulants yeah and
once the we don't have to go down this
this this path because I want to I want
you to be able to focus on on these
these definitions but where I got myself
into trouble was having never been
physically addicted to any substance
before mm-hmm I started using the ECA
stack once a day my friend was using it
twice a day I started using it twice a
day and then I start using it three
times a day develop a tolerance very
quickly right more and more and if you
stopped withdrawal symptoms or
absolutely something I had never
experienced that so I continued after
sports to use this and certainly in the
long term there are some some very nasty
side effects but I didn't stop me for
many many years well so there's a great
link between ATD and addictions and not
just because they both begin with the
same three letters and I can tell you
about my own ADHD and this is a way to
go back to childhood again so that
tuning out that absent-mindedness the
desire to scatter your attention all
over the place that's not a disease they
say it's a inherited disease the hell it
is that tuning out divided attention is
actually but let me give you a personal
question again if I were to become
abusive towards you right now verbally
or otherwise what would be your options
right now I could ignore you but that's
not what you would do first is it not
likely I mean I would right now I would
probably just listen and pause my I shut
down off and if I get attacked verbally
because I don't want to respond with
rage which has historically been my
response I hear you but but let's get a
bit more basic about it
the rational response if I were to
become abusive would be for you to just
assert yourself saying don't talk to me
that way right or will be to leave
saying this in two years over mm-hmm and
if for some reason you had not the
strength to do it either of those
there's other people in the room here
with us you could ask for help right but
what if you couldn't escape fight back
or seek help then you would shut down or
tune out right now there's the tuning
out is simply a defensive response on
the part of the brain now put me back
into my infancy when my mother's so
grief-stricken that I'm crying cause
she's in pain and I'll read you a quote
here if I may yes please and this has to
do with the sensitive child the child is
very open and can feel the pain and
suffering and going on its immediate
environment the child is aware of his
own body and can also feel the tension
rigidity and pain in the body of the
mother of anyone else he's with if the
mother suffering the baby suffers too
the pain never gets discharged the
organism does not develop the confidence
that it can regulate itself that things
will happen the way they should
hence lack of optimism okay you know
mama didn't abuse me she did her best to
look after me but she was stressed
depressed terrorized geef stricken I'm
picking that up as a sensitive infant
can I fight back change the situation or
escape none of those what can I do
nothing I can do my brain will tune out
as a way of dealing with the stress so
I'm not talking about abuse here
understand what stress muttering or
parenting the child's brain then we'll
tune out when is the trust painting to
newing out when the brain is developing
so the tuning out then becomes
programmed in is the default setting and
that's why a DD so not an inherited
disease it's not a disease at all it
begins as a coping mechanism which then
gets programmed the brain and there's a
lot of these early coping mechanisms
function they
you in the short-term create problems in
the long-term and that's a TD is one of
these examples and of course it also
most more poem makes you more prone to
be addicted because now when you tune
out life becomes less interesting you
shut down emotional you protect yourself
now you feel depressed
what does depression actually means you
said you were depressed what a
depression mean to depress something is
to push it down what do people push it
on in depression they pushed on their
emotions why would they because the
emotions are too painful so even
depression becomes as a coping mechanism
you push it down so you don't feel the
pain but then later on that interferes
with your life functioning so it all
begins as a coping mechanism and later
on becomes a source of dysfunction and
all this is happening when the brain is
actually developing which we can talk
about later so these are the links I
began to make including after I was
diagnosed with it so I and then despite
the fact that a couple of my kids were
diagnosed I knew that this wasn't the
genetic disease that what it is actually
is a coping mechanism and had which got
programmed to the brain and then when I
read the literature on brain development
Wow
terms of the human brain is shaped by
the environment and particularly by the
adult child relationships and so it all
began to make perfect sense to me so
there's a few things I'd love to
underscore or reiterate because I think
they're very student very helpful and
certainly if I had had some of these
reframes I think that I would have been
able to be proactive with working on a
lot of my own issues much much earlier
mm-hmm me too by the way yeah for
instance so we can come back to this I'm
actually just going to mention two
things and then we can we can go where
that takes us but the first is rather
than asking why the addiction asking why
the pain so instead of looking at the
the consequences looking at the causes
there and not confusing the these
symptoms with the causes
so instead of asking why the addiction
asking why the pain and the the other
this this might take a moment for me to
read but I think it's worth reading and
I should say that compassion for
addiction this is an organization
co-founded by you yourself and Vicki I'm
gonna make a guess I've never actually
said her last name but do lie or do lie
Vicki just for for context for folks who
are wondering I was actually the very
first person about five years ago to
recommend that we meet and then I took a
note of it in a notebook I still have
and that's part of the reason that I
reached out for the book and just
because we may revisit this I met Vicki
at a gathering at the home of someone
named George Sarlo right who has a lot
in cares a lot of common background with
you and certainly common interests but
what we'll come back to that the part
that I wanted to read is is the
following and I'm gonna make my make an
attempt here alright so the mainstream
view of addiction you mentioned this
compared to the clinical perspectives
that addiction is a matter of individual
choice moral failure or weakness which
is why so many approaches are based on
deterrence and Punishment which includes
self-help approaches for that matter
that that I've attempted myself the
clinical view is that addiction is a
disease of the brain with disordered
brain circuits and behaviors and
accurate yet narrow perspective so I
think that's that's a really important
aligned and accurate yet narrow
perspective
so perhaps accurate but incomplete right
it is accurate that in the addicted
brain that the addicted brain is
demonstrably a physiologically
dysfunctional brain but narrow because
it seeks to explain the dysfunction in
strictly physiological and biochemical
terms without recognize the emotional
and social component of how the brain
works and this was really driven home
for me recently
in the last several years I've gotten to
know Tony Robbins yes and I attended an
event not too long ago with several of
my very close friends called date with
destiny
and at this event he asks the audience
of 5,000 people how many people here
know someone who takes antidepressants
pretty much every hand goes up how many
people here know someone who takes
antidepressants yet is still depressed
and is probably 80% of the people who
raise their hands the first time and I
personally know quite a few people who
take antidepressants which seem to help
on some level yeah although the
tolerance for some of these
pharmaceuticals can also be developed
very quickly and yet if if my experience
is anything like the experience of or I
should say if the experiences of other
people is anything like my personal
experience with friends let's say you
have depression you witness these
thought patterns and verbal patterns
that can take them from the highest high
or just a baseline of optimism and drive
them back into depression and so they're
just it seems to be just from an
empirical or observational standpoint
more to the story and so I really
appreciate you putting into words what
I've grasped to try to understand and
also convey so with this definition of
addiction how do you work with patients
well mm-hmm let's go back to what I said
what you quoted me saying not why the
addiction but why the pain so if we
understand that addiction in every case
is rooted in some painful internal
experience and that in when you ask
people what does the addiction do for
you they'll say it numbs me it soothes
the pain it makes me feel connected with
other people
it gives me a sense of control it gives
me inner peace or the lack of inner
peace the lack of control the lack of
connection they all forms of emotional
pain if I ask the question not why the
addiction but why the pain then that
leads to an examination of that person's
life rather than looking just at their
brain chemistry so I'm quoted from an
article
appeared in the journal Pediatrics which
is the official Journal of the American
Academy of Pediatrics it's about as
pastiches as you can get 2012 the
article comes from the Harvard Center on
the developing child again a prestigious
child development research institution
at Harvard University this article did
not present new information so much as
it elegantly summarized decades of
research and notice what they say they
say growing scientific evidence
demonstrates that social and physical
environments that threaten human
development because of scarcity stress
or instability can lead to short-term
physiologic and psychological
adjustments that are necessary for
immediate survival and adaptation but
which may come at a significant cost to
long-term outcomes in learning behavior
health and longevity that's what I was
saying before that was really
adaptations like pushing down your
feelings when the pushing of things are
too painful we'll help you as an infant
it's young young child but then they
cause problems later on the tuning out
that you do to protect you from the
stress in your environment if you're
very sensitive it doesn't take a lot of
stress helps you and your but in the
long term becomes the problem that's
exactly what they're saying now I'll
jump a few pages ahead to what they say
about brain development then this is so
crucial and it's so crucial because they
still don't teach this to medical
schools even though scientifically it's
not even vaguely controversial the human
brain develops an interaction with the
environment it's not genetically
programmed early here's what they say
the architecture of the brain is
constructed to an ongoing process that
begins before birth continues into
adulthood and establishes either a
sturdy or a fragile foundation for all
the health learning and behavior that
follow not some of the health learning
all the health learning no notice what
they say first of all the architecture
of the brain is constructed through
ongoing process that begins before birth
which already means what happens in the
womb already is an impact on you so if
your mother is stressed and she's got
high levels of stress hormone that's
already affecting your brain development
and when you think all the stress
pregnant women out there no wonder we've
seen so many kids in trouble and we know
from American Studies international
studies that when mothers are stressed
their placenta will naturally have more
cortisol and adrenaline the stress
hormone those kids will be more likely
to have stress issues later on abnormal
stress hormone levels even at 1 year of
age behavior problems learning problems
and so on which tells us a lot as to why
adapted kids adopted kids have so many
more problems that's another issue but
the next paragraph is key the
interactions of genes and experiences
literally shapes the circuitry of the
developing brain and it's critical in
critically influenced by in other words
the circuitry that chemistry of the
brain and which centers and which
circuits and which systems develop and
which neural chemicals we'll be
presenting what quantities depends on
the early environment and is quickly
influenced by the mutual responsiveness
of adult-child relationships
particularly in the early childhood
years in other words the most important
influence shaping the physiological
development of the brain is the quality
of parent-child relationships now when
parents are stressed or distracted or
workaholics like I was a young parent if
there's instability economic troubles
relationship troubles unresolved trauma
on the part of the parent loving parents
who are just stressed
that'll interfere with the child's brain
development that's why we're seeing so
much weight eh Deena so much more autism
and so much of other problems because of
stress in society that affects the
parenting environment in other words yes
there's physiological problems with the
brain but it's not a genetic issue it's
really at the early experience so when
you look at brain scans of adults that
are troubled brain scans as you do an
addict's you're not just looking at the
impact of addiction you're also looking
at the impact of childhood trauma and
childhood stress and this has been shown
over and over and over and over again so
there's no separation between the
physiology and the psychology so if you
come to me as an addict and you say I
got such-and-such and I ask you what
does it do for you and you say it numbs
the pain that my question is where did
you develop the pain what happened
and then we have an inquiry and not no
longer becomes a shameful thing that you
chose this note doesn't mean that you're
stuck with it because you've got this
generating problem we get it as an
adaptive response to something that
happened and we can heal that the reason
why addiction treatment is failing is
because physicians don't understand is
they keep dealing with the effects which
is the addiction and the behaviors which
was the effects of the addiction but not
the cause which is the childhood
distress and
the impact to charter distress that
carry into adulthood
in other words hugs they're prisoners of
childhood and so present methods of
treatment in psychiatry and addiction
medicine in childhood psychiatry deal
with effects rather than causes and this
is why we're so ineffective at it I've
I've many questions yeah so the you know
the first is just to to underscore
something which is you know the our
software in the genetics play a role but
but it's it's not a comprehensive
explanation for what we're discussing
here genes can predispose but they don't
predetermine what exactly no there are
very few genetic diseases there's one
runs in my family muscular dystrophy if
you've got the gene you'll have the
disease and I pet my mother had it
predetermined that just predetermined
very various diseases
let me tell an interesting study from
either Australia in New Zealand they
looked at a group of people for
aggression they found that the most
aggressive people had a certain gene
variant do you think they found the gene
for aggression no they didn't because
the least aggressive people in the group
had the same gene so the most aggressive
and the least aggressive shared the same
gene as compared to the average the gene
could not have been for aggression now
if you actually looked at the life
histories of those people the most
aggressive people had been brought up in
troubled sometimes abusive but always
very stressed homes the least aggressive
were brought up in very nurturing homes
what was the gene for sensitivity
the more sensitive you are the more
you're gonna be affected when you
brought up in a peaceful home you're
gonna be that much more peaceful when
you're brought up in a stormy home
you're gonna be that much more
aggressive so there are these
predispositions but they're not for
specific illnesses they are for
temperament right which means that
you're gonna be more or less affected by
the environment and so yeah there's some
pea disposing genes will be no both from
animal studies in monkey studies and
human studies that even you find a gene
that for similar reasons predisposes
somebody to addiction if that animal or
if that human being is brought up in a
good nurturing circumstances their risk
of addiction is no greater than
creatures without that gene right so
it's just not a genetic disease an
effect it runs in families doesn't prove
anything because you know as I always
point out I'm a medical doctor and if
two of my kids become medical doctors or
which is no danger whatsoever but if
they did that wouldn't prove that the
practice of medicine is a genetic
disease all right all right it's it's
it's not a it's not a catch-all
explanation also you have I mean because
of a few of the books I've written I
hear a lot of stories both successful
and unsuccessful about people attempting
to lose weight and they'll often say
well it runs in my family like my
parents are fat my grandparents are fat
and they'll say do you have pets I'll
say yes I'll say your pets overweight no
yeah my pets are fat okay that's clearly
clearly not just a genetic issue well
may I say something on that yeah but
have you heard about the adverse
childhood experiences studies the ACA
studies the average child adverse child
a dress childhood experiences studies
you know I haven't but I feel like
there's a questionnaire or a series
there's a test that you can tell yeah
there is so the adverse childhood
experiences studies were done in
California with I think seventeen
fourteen or seventeen thousand adults
mostly Caucasians half of them
University educated and they looked at
the relationship between childhood
adversity and adult outcomes and an
adverse childhood experience was defined
as physical or sexual or emotional abuse
a divorce apparent being jailed
violence in the family apparent being
addicted appending mentally ill apparent
dying these were the main ones and for
each of these adverse childhood
experiences the risk of addiction goes
up exponentially the risk of autoimmune
disease go up the risk of depression
goes up the risk of ADHD goes up the
risk of relationship problems STDs
everything goes up now you know how
these studies started these studies
started in obesity clinic the dr.
Vincent felitti was a San Diego
internist wonderful guy deep thinker and
and researcher they noticed that at this
clinic with rigorous dietary control and
exercise they could help people lose
weight but what do you think they
couldn't do it couldn't ensure they
continue those behaviors when they live
exactly they couldn't have them keep it
off and then felitti did something
that's I have to say is unusual for a
medical doctor he listened to his
patients and they said don't you get it
we're stuffing down our pain this is all
based on shelter trauma and so obesity
itself is a response to childhood trauma
it's just another addiction yeah I could
talk about in many ways but and the
adverse childhood experiences studies
have been repeated numerous times now in
other countries always with the same
results and so that the obesity epidemic
right now is not just an epidemic of
junk foods and and and and sedentary
lifestyles that is true yeah those are
contributing factors but but the
underlying basis is people self-soothing
their stresses in their lives so it's
really an epidemic of stress says let me
return to another point or one thing you
said in passing which I'd love to dig
into a little bit and that was how at
the time say the example I think we were
discussing well actually before that let
me mention one thing so I've had my
entire my full genome sequence mm-hmm a
predisposition to alcoholism is very
prevalent my family from a genetic
standpoint just from a software basis
however
I mentioned earlier I never had issues
with alcohols with stimulants so just
just as just as a footnote but what I
was going to what I'd love to ask you
and then I'd really love to hear what
you do with patience once you start
looking at their pain and the tools you
use or the approaches you use but the
one of the epiphanies for me in the last
very recent year or two hmm has been
looking at my coping mechanisms very
differently and what I mean by that is
for a very long time I had certain
behaviors certain defaults that I hated
which of course means I'm hating a part
of myself that's right
and that included anger rage responses
yeah use of stimulants you name it a
close friend of mine who is a therapist
but I've never I've never engaged him as
a therapist and there's certainly plenty
of bad therapists out there which i
think is a separate topic nonetheless he
was helping and I'm sure we'll get back
to this but in preparation for a very
controlled supervised psychedelic
experience he was helping another friend
of ours mm-hmm prepare this is with MDMA
this is with ayahuasca food Iowa's
cocaine and this this person had a
number of addictions and she hated these
addictions and she said I hate these I
realized they're they're terrible
they've they've ruined my life they're
ruining my life and it was all a
negative relationship to these behaviors
and he said did these ever serve you did
these ever help what did these do for
you exactly and she and she described
how they helped her cope with very
difficult circumstances early on and he
said perhaps what you should do as an
exercise and what we can do is for you
to effectively thank those behavior have
suffer the role they played and for the
necessity they filled and
to then recognize you thank them for
their duty effectively but to let them
go because they're no longer needed and
that was a huge eye-opener for me and I
began to this is coinciding with a
number of things and I want to take us
off the rails but began to use something
called loving-kindness meditation or
Metta my Metta Emmy TT a meditation
which I was introduced to by a gentleman
from Google actually a formerly Google
chade-meng tan and then also jack
Kornfield who really reiterate it for me
of course but I never applied it to
myself I always applied this
loving-kindness meditation to other
people and what was recommended is that
I apply that loving-kindness to these to
the younger Tim to the other versions of
Tim who had these behaviors that I had
grown to hate and resent and to actually
thank them for the role they played for
instance that rage that anger was the
fuel that got me out of Long Island and
where I grew up there a lot of serious
drug issues particularly with opiates my
best friend I had a fentanyl many of my
friends are addicted to opiates who I
grew up with many have died and I got
out because I was angry in part I think
that was the fuel but that fuel ended up
over the long term being very corrosive
but to in a way to reconcile myself with
that I had to stop resenting it and I
suppose that's maybe more of a
confession than a question but your
comment brought it to mind and maybe as
a segue I just love to hear and we can
take it anywhere we want of course but
once you have shifted the focus from why
the addiction to why the pain and you
start to work with someone what
approaches have you found to help what
tools well so I very much salute your
friends approach it's exactly what the
approach I would take myself and I call
it compassionate inquiry so inquiry in a
compassionate way now why did I do this
but hmm why did I do this right the
first one is not a question it's a
statement it's a self condemnation the
second one is a question
mmm wonder why did this ah he soothed my
pain and so what your friend said that
it served you so thank it love it but
let go of it is absolutely right I call
it the stupid friend the stupid founders
is the one who helped you in a
particular way at a certain time but it
can't learn that that way doesn't
function anymore
right that instead of helping no it's
hurting so it's a friend because it's
really trying to help but it's stupid
because it's not learning that you no
longer that three year although that's
five year although that's fifteen year
old you know so this not this leads to
the the question of trauma because it's
one thing to recognize that all this
originates in shotted pain it's quite
another to transform that pain and for
that we have to understand what trauma
is so people often think that trauma is
what happens to you so trauma is a
divorce when you were small and your
parents fighting trauma is your mother's
depression trauma as your father's
alcoholism trauma is your parents
argumentation traumas physical or sexual
abuse or some loss those aren't the
traumas those are traumatic but the
trauma is not what happens to you the
traumas what happens inside you and as a
result of these traumatic events what
happens inside you is yet you get
disconnected from your emotions and you
disconnected from your body and you have
difficulty being in the present moment
and you develop a negative view of your
world and a negative view of yourself
and a defensive view of other people and
these perspectives keep show up in your
life in the present because they're the
stupid friends and so the issue is not
just to recognize what happened at ten
fifteen thirty however many years ago
but to actually recognize their
manifestations in the present moment and
to transcend them and all you do that by
reconnecting with yourself by restoring
the connection with your body primarily
and material motions that you lost and
once you do when you found these things
again then you have what we call
recovery because what does it mean to
recover something
it needs to find it again so what is it
that people find when they recover they
find themselves and the loss of self is
the essence of trauma so the real
purpose of of addiction treatment mental
health treatment any kind of healing is
reconnection for people who are
listening and want to reconnect with
themselves with their bodies for
instance what recommendations might you
have whether that's things they can do
or resources they can can look to or
both or something else what what
recommendations I'm sure I could
actually I am a hundred percent sure
because I've had people come on and for
the very first time on this podcast talk
about sexual abuse the interns as
children and what they did to help
recover from that many people listening
I am sure have addictions both traumatic
past experiences and trauma
what what recommendations could you bake
for them sure so I want to say first of
all that for trauma you don't need
therapy traumatic events so there's two
ways to look at them one is that bad
things happen I shouldn't have we've
talked about those but the other way to
get traumatized is when good things
happen that should have happened so if
the good good things didn't happen that
should have happened sorry so when you
look look at the Shroud of omission
trauma connection with the parents not
that they didn't love you not that they
didn't do their best but they were too
stressed traumatize distracted
themselves then you didn't get the kind
of attention and the kind of acceptance
and the kind of attuned being with that
you needed that itself can make you
disconnect from yourself the child needs
that acceptance that connection that
attunement our brain development
requires that our emotional development
demands it and when we don't get it not
because the parents don't love us but
some people because of their own issues
we can also suffer that disconnection so
that's what I call developmental trauma
and now how do we connect well there are
many many forms of therapy
it's very difficult for anybody to do
this on their own some people do it I
certainly couldn't do it on my own I've
needed a lot of help in terms of therapy
that helps me understand what happened
to me and so that there's there's a
reason for it so that not as if there's
a reason for it then it's no longer me
I'm not somebody to be ashamed of I'm
just somebody developed on certain lines
for some very good reasons but it's not
in my deepest character and it's not who
I am and I don't have to be that way
that's a relief to know it's also not
that I'm generically programs I'm doomed
to stay that way you know number one
number two you have to reconnect with
the body there are various body
therapies my friend Peter Levine and his
somatic experiencing walking Tigers
waking the time waking with her waking
the tiger was his first book and he's
written many wonderful books since then
so somatic somatic experiencing his
method is called which he develops it's
brilliant there is EMDR eye movement
desensitization reprogramming which is a
way of bypassing the conscious mind and
getting to the emotional brain and
quicker than talk therapy by itself can
do so it's combined with talk therapy
but it takes you past just a conscious
defensive egoic mind there is the
emotional freedom tapping that people do
there's race variations on that there is
there's motor sensory integration
techniques there is then there is the
traditional therapies like yoga now yoga
was not simply a physical modality when
it first developed yoga actually means
unity so the very essence of yoga is to
regain that unity not just with
ourselves but also with the larger
creation and so yoga when it's practiced
in its intended way not just the hot
yoga where you get a good workout that's
great and not against it but I'm talking
about intentional yoga with a meditative
aspect to it which is taught by a number
of disciplines
bodywork of all kinds can hit pause for
one second do you practice yoga and if
so what type do you practice so I have
always said with my ADHD I'm not a yoga
person I can't do it until you now half
ago I met actually a yogi
his name is Sadhguru and he's Indian
yogi with a big following I was very
skeptical but I met the guy I know I
have a 50 minutes daily yoga practice
which I did this morning before coming
to the end to you and this made an
enormous difference in my life with my
ADHD mind I really have trouble just
sitting there when I sit on the
meditation cushion my mind is like all
over the place but with the yoga which
is more body based I can stay much more
present there is a meditation of
component to it and so the answer is yes
if you had asked me 18 months ago I
would have said no I support it but I
don't do it but now I'm actually a very
committed practitioner and and its
really has made a difference is there
particular is it a particular type of
yoga that people could Google or learn
more about well so I'm not a yoga expert
and there's many forms of yoga that
other people more knowledgeable than I
am could recommend but the one I learned
is called inner engineering and it's
taught by either said gurus followers
and you can look up inner engineering
online imagine when I recommended to
France and others everybody has been
only being grateful so I can highly
recommend it typically there's to me
what seems to be a cult around the guy
which I don't take too particularly but
he's the genuine article in terms of
having a deep experience and being able
to try and submit that experience to
others and creating a practical system
around it so it's worked for me I'm not
here to recruit anybody else but since
you're asking no no that's just my fans
appreciate yeah well you know I'm not
gonna blame it on my fans I like
specifics much yeah so inner engineering
you can look up online and it's taught
here in the States and in Canada
internationally actually and I but I did
interrupt you you're about to mention I
think another technique or modality that
can help talked about for instance the
somatic experience EMDR emotional
freedom technique motor sensory
integration technique
techniques yoga and then there's
something coming up after that well
about ten years ago I began to work with
psychedelics now if you're 15 years ago
you were to ask me will ever be working
with psychedelics as a healing modality
I would have said you're out of your
mind
but then through a series of events
might became aware of the potential role
of psychedelics in healing and I've been
doing work with them for ten years and
there are another potent method and
they're not for everybody and I have to
emphasize that whatever modality you
choose of a psychedelic nature you have
to do it with adept practitioners with
deep integrity and deep knowledge and
experience but in such hands and in such
a context it's can be like a
superhighway to the self awareness not
in isolation but it opens doors that
otherwise might take years and so it's
not unusual for me to conduct the
psychedelic session at somebody or
series of sessions either in a group or
individual setting and have them say
that was like ten years of psychotherapy
in one day and I've had the same
experience myself so again it's not to
be isolated from other kinds of work and
it has to be integrated but it's not a
potent way of working and of course as I
know you're personally aware there's an
increasing movement amongst
psychologists therapists psychiatrists
medical doctors other healers to find
ways of incorporating incorporating
psychedelic healing in the larger
therapeutic scheme you mentioned as it
related to EMDR and some of these other
techniques that you that you listed that
it is a potent way of bypassing the
egoic mind yeah and certainly
psychedelics literally mind manifesting
that's right in that case our one very
potent tool that or they are tools that
have been used for millennia in
traditional or ceremonial contexts
around the world for many purposes but
including bypassing the analytical
rational prefrontal cortex in many
capacities
now you mentioned a series of events and
I will come back to the psychedelics and
ask you which you have chosen and why
should work with but if if you can
mention any of them what were the series
of events that led you sure to miss to
psychedelics and 2008 my book on
addiction in the realm of hungry ghosts
Close Encounters with addiction was
published in Canada and very quickly
became a number-one national bestseller
subsequently published in the States as
well and I was in a book tour and people
could ask me what do you know about
addictions and I was cause the treatment
ayahuasca being a Peruvian or Amazonian
vine that's made into a brew that has
psychedelic properties I knew nothing
the next speech the next event somebody
else would ask what do you know bruh I
was going to another addiction I think
started getting annoyed with it like
leave me alone I've just written a book
I've spent years researching it my life
experience and all kinds of scientific
exploration went into it asked me about
something I know about and then I
realized that maybe the universe was
knocking on my door and somebody said
did you know you could experience it
here in Vancouver there was a Peruvian
shaman leading some ceremonies up in
Vancouver so who might have say no when
I jumped right in and I sat in this tent
with 50 other people 50 yeah I was
that's thought I set it up it's not it's
not what I recommend but that's how they
set it up
they played beautiful music and there
was a little baby in the room mother and
dad were there for the experience the
baby was in the room and the baby was
cooing away and tears started flowing
down my face and these were not tears of
sorrow they were tears of joy and I got
in touch with such profound love that I
had never consciously experienced before
and if there were tears of love and it
wasn't love for anybody in particular it
was just
and then I saw in all the ways that I
had closed my heart against love in my
life and how I betrayed love in my
personal relationship with my spouse and
and and and my children and in other
ways so I just got this experience of
love is something profound and and and
universal and and life-defining but
something from I've been cut off in so
many ways and I got it because I closed
my heart against love
precisely because when I was wrong about
small I've been so hurt I went to my
mother states of mind she couldn't
respond to me where I needed to be
responded to not her fault but she
couldn't and then when I was a year old
she gave me to a stranger to save my
life and I didn't see her for a month
which is a huge explain that for a
second
so again it's Budapest Hungary Seconal
or January the Russians are circled
Budapest and are not fighting the
Germans the government in power is a
right-wing fascist anti-semitic military
force and even though the deportations
of Jews had stopped the Germans had an
elated half a million Hungarian Jews in
three or four months but now the
Hungarian fascists for killing Jews in
Budapest and including in the house
where my mother I were living so my
mother gave me to a stranger in the
street a Christian woman because she
didn't know she'd be dead or alive next
day well or that I would be and I was
quite sick so I didn't see her from us
which I experiences a deep abandoned
house could I experience it so my heart
closes against love and I got all this
and so I got that if this plant this
plant that as you say manifests the mind
can show me both the ways in which have
closed the off from myself and that I
don't need to because the love is still
there what healing potential it has now
I wish I could say that after that
experience I became a loving house
and I loving human being I didn't it's
not that simple as my wife could tell
you nevertheless it opened the door for
me and I got right away now however the
thought that I had was that I had no
induction I had had no introduction I
had no processing afterwards ayahuasca
is a medicinal plant that has been used
in the Amazon basin for hundreds of
years maybe longer in its a cultural
context in a tribe in a village where
people know each other would they know
the shaman where they shared the same
assumptions in the same history that's
not the same as a bunch of Westerner
strangers to each other come together
for one night drinking the stuff and
then going their separate ways
agreed so immediately the question that
came up for me was how can we create a
setting that at least resembles as best
we can fashion the original setting so
we came up with the idea where we treat
where a small number of people get
together with properly trained shamans
who have integrity and experience deep
experience and with me facilitating
people's preparation and their post
ceremony integration and so I've been
doing that now for 10 years and a lot of
learning involved we made mistakes but
it evolved and the essence of it is that
people don't come into it cold they come
into the preparation in a safe setting
where pretty soon group becomes a family
to each other which means that no do
they love each other and support each
other but they also trigger each other
and I mean basically I tell people I
guess what you're back and you found
your virgin and everything you hated
about your film urgent is going to show
up here but in the context where it's
safe for that to happen right and so
I've seen a lot of great healing I've
had people with multiple suicide
attempts heal from depression I've seen
people get much better with the
autoimmune diseases I've seen people
deal with all kinds of addictions and
life issues relationship problems come
out of it much more themselves much more
able to
deal with these issues so long as the
proper integration is done afterwards so
that was my personal experience now that
Dan introduced me to the whole world of
psychedelics and I realized that there's
a lot of research being done these days
that his organization Maps
multidisciplinary association
association for psychedelic studies
which is a group of psychologists
psychiatrists medical doctors therapists
counselors interested people to study
scientifically the role of psychedelics
in healing and as you're probably aware
interesting studies have been done
around psilocybin mushrooms and
end-of-life anxiety studies have been
done which are revolutionary in using
mdma-assisted psychotherapy and they may
being the medical name for a technical
name for ecstasy again in the right
setting with the right leadership these
have proven to be very powerful
modalities of healing and so there's a
whole new resurgence of psychedelic
research in a number of different areas
some of the manmade some of the
plant-based but there's a whole world
that I was introduced to and I've
learned a lot in the last ten years and
again I both practice it in my own
healing work and I'm interested in it
also as a participant so I'd love to add
a few things to your second comment and
then ask a bunch of questions about the
first yeah so for people who are
interested in learning more about the
current scientific studies and
mechanisms of action related to some of
these compounds and what is being done
there are a number of very interesting
and very competent organizations as far
as I can tell
Maps is one that you measure and I'll
actually be seeing the founder Rick
Doblin
in just a few days time there is the
Hefner Institute which I've worked with
primarily run by MDS and PhDs or at
least the board and so on is comprised
of of scientists and medical doctors
it was through the Hefner foundation and
also directly with Johns Hopkins so I've
had some involvement with the South
seventh with psilocybin studies and
actually thank you to many of you served
with smacking the mic too many of you in
my audience who helped through a crowd
running funding campaign to raise funds
for a study at Johns Hopkins related to
treatment treatment resistant depression
yes it's all seven so Haftar institute
excellent organization organization to
look into and then you Sona also which I
believe is primarily focused on
psilocybin whereas maps at this point
has done great work on many levels
including helping to facilitate MDMA
being designated a breakthrough therapy
and effectively getting fast tracked
into Phase three trials by the FDA
that's right yeah and these are all
organizations that I would encourage
people to look into and it's really an
exciting time and also a fragile time as
it relates to these compounds which have
certainly demonstrated historically
accepting MDMA let's just look at the
studies many of which were done starting
and say 50s and 60s looking at the
clinical efficacy of using these
compounds for everything ranging from
alcoholism to nicotine addiction to many
of the things that you mentioned well in
order what is little known but that Bill
Wilson dr. bill who funded one of the
funders of AAA right actually had some
powerful LSD experiences
and which helped him is in his spiritual
growth listen hey they don't talk about
that very much but it's a fact if I'm a
parent that usually say as much as I
support the 12 steps what a also doesn't
tend to talk about is the trauma that
first causes the addiction and Bill
Wilson himself was a traumatized child
he was abandoned by his parents I mean
he was very young and so it's
interesting that AAA for all the good
work that it does do which I support I
don't support people being forced into
any particular form of treatment but as
a self chosen form of treatment it can
be very helpful to many people but they
don't talk about two very interesting
things which is one is the psychedelic
part and the other is the Toronto part
yeah no it's for me just looking at my
own childhood experiences and exploring
recovery defined as you defined it yeah
in in the last several years especially
in the last six months it's been
fascinating and frustrating to discover
and try to piece together these various
elements but the what is the frustrating
part that there is well there may it may
exist but I couldn't find one-stop
shopping that checked all the boxes
right ain't any right so so it's it's
been an exercise in collecting various
tools and piecing them together like you
said you a a does incredible work and
they they what they have done in terms
of a distributed free service with
social accountability in support is
incredible so they the psychedelic
component which bill actually wanted to
as I understand it make one of the steps
in a needless to say was hard to get
widespread leadership support for that
and then you have the trauma piece so
these are all tools in the toolkit that
people can use for their own sort of
bespoke approach in some respects coming
back to the ayahuasca specifically and I
should just as a caveat point out
because I do think that these tools
I know these tools are very powerful I
have first-hand familiarity from past
experiences and have have been very
engaged with this scientific community
for some time now they can be misused
there are many charlatans and
unfortunately there's more you know
there's many there's some very powerful
healers shamans who unfortunately
exploit people sexually and financially
very common yeah and this is of course
not just restricted to the Iowa school
world it's also happens in a spiritual
world from the spiritual leaders with
tremendous power tremendous healing
influence have at the same time
Exploited men and women
and created all kinds of further trauma
so unfortunately when you have that much
power and you haven't totally done your
integration work you can start misusing
that power and that happens in all the
healing modalities as we know but it
certainly happens in a psychedelic world
as well
yeah it's very it's I wish I could say
it's rare it's not but it's something to
safeguard against especially when you're
in that vulnerable state so I would
actually recommend that people see a
documentary called Kumari which is very
much worth watching and the brief
overview is it's an Indian filmmaker
who begins studying various gurus and
healers in the u.s. I in in hopes of I
believe the original impetus was to
simply do a documentary on charlatans
and then he went to India and he said
they're just as bad here and he said are
just as bad or worse and he decides to
make himself a guru as a as an
experiment and it's it's a very
thought-provoking documentary that I
think will actually becomes the kind of
fake or right it's right yeah I remember
it yeah and he unveils it yeah I don't
want to give too much away but it's very
well done very worth watching because it
helps to prepare you I think
psychologically to not lose yourself in
a dangerous way and here's the problem
you see what I said about the essence of
trauma is that you you lose connection
to yourself and that means you lose
connection to your gut feelings right
you know as long as your gut feelings
are with you and your honor them they'll
protect you but the very sense of trauma
is the loss of that yeah which means
that when you lose connection to God
feelings then you're very vulnerable to
being exploited and when you talk to
people who were exploited in any context
psychedelic or not if you ask them do
you have any kind of vague sense that
this is not quite right they'll say yeah
but I didn't listen to it yep and the
fact that they didn't listen to it is
already a marker of trauma so since it's
traumatized people which is most of us
who seek healing
it's also vulnerable people who seek
healing and this is what some of these
people can exploit so the very portal
into healing which is opening up the
vulnerability that we've shut down
against is also the portal for potential
loss so people have to do their due
diligence yeah and I'm not trying to
create paranoia here but people just
should be careful you just mentioned
something that I'd really love to just
pause and emphasize you mentioned a few
things so number one is that your your
gut feeling
/ it's like physiological intuition can
help you mm-hmm and that's something
that for many reasons I completely muted
or ignored for a very long time so it's
been a process of getting reacquainted
with that and I would say two things
that that I found helpful and if you
have any comments on second in
particular I'd love love to hear one was
dramatically decreasing my caffeine
intake which I found was almost like
turning up the volume on static made it
very difficult for me to read or feel
that's other things it's I was using it
maybe for many reasons but it had the
side effect at least of muting maybe
that was why I did it subconsciously
many of these feelings ii was in fact a
video that was recommended to me but it
corresponds to a book called the gift of
fear by Gavin de Becker and who actually
owns a company that does protective
services and executive security so you
have to keep in mind maybe you don't
always want to ask a barber if you need
a haircut so keeping that in mind it it
also in brief points to the benefits of
some of these reactions or emotional
states that we are prone to labeling
negative yeah and the as you said not to
make anyone paranoid but rather to
inform them
these are currently existent risks and
one of the hopes certainly with say
ultimately better researching these
compounds after they've been really
unfairly but for understandable reasons
politicized and put into the same
schedule in the United States as heroin
and cocaine to have them rescheduled so
that they are prescribed 'el in if then
that happens the ability to certify
therapists to regulate and to maintain a
a broad type of quality control goes up
so that's also so one of the hopes is
that that will decrease the likelihood
of bad actors and allow appropriate
punishment for bad actors because mind
you as we know even in legalized
legitimate professions it still happens
this is stuff happen it's the most so
ultimately you know gut feelings are
still the best response and let me
address first why we shut down our gut
feelings if I may please so a human
being has two fundamental needs apart
from the physical needs in infancy in
childhood one is for attachment now
attachment is the closeness and
proximity with another human being for
the sake of being looked after or for
the sake of looking after the other
human beings as mammals and even birds
are creatures of attachment we have to
connect and attach because otherwise we
don't survive if there's nobody that's
motivated to take care of us to attach
to us that way and we've not motivated
to attach to others we just can't
survive one additional thing is is that
the endorphins which are the body's
internal opiate like chemicals which
heroin and all the other opiates
resemble they have to facilitate
attachment so if you take infant mice
and you're knock out their and orphan
receptors so they don't have endorphin
opiate activity in their brain they
won't cry for help and separated from
their mothers
which would mean that they would die in
the wild and which goes back to what
happens in early in childhood when
there's stress and trauma these these
endorphin systems don't develop and then
when people do heroin it feels like a
war soft hug to them they feel love and
connection for the first time that's why
it's so powerful but so we had this need
for attachment without which obviously
the human infant was the most helpless
the most dependent the least mature of
any creature in the universe at birth
cannot survive without the attachment
and that attachment relationship given
that me of the longest period of
development of any creature you know
well into adolescence and and beyond
attachment is not a negotiable need but
we have another need which is
authenticity
now authenticity although the self means
being connected to ourselves just
knowing what we feel and being able to
act on it so that means our gut feelings
so let's look at how human beings
evolved 400 thousands of years and 400
thousand years or so of this species
existing on earth how did we live we
didn't live in cities and houses and so
on millet they're out there in the wild
until very recently in human existence
now just how long do you survive in the
wild if you're not connected to your gut
feelings not very long not very long if
you start using your intellect instead
of your gut feelings you just don't
survive so that's a powerful survival
need as well so attachment is a survival
need authenticity survival need but what
happens if your authenticity threatens
your attachment relationships for
example is a two-year-old you get angry
because you can get that cookie before
dinner but your parents can't handle
anger because they grew up in homes when
there was rage ilysm and they're
terrified that the very expression of
anger so they give you the message that
good old kids don't get angry the
message you receive is not that good
look is don't get angry but the angry
little kids don't get loved because your
parents are now sullen they won't look
at you they talk to you in a harsh way
you're not getting loved not
experiencing love at that moment now
diversely attached guess what you're
gonna suppress the authenticity every
time and this is obvious connection to
ourselves and to our gut feelings so
that strangely enough that very dynamic
which is essential for human survival in
a natural setting not becomes a threat
to our survival in his in this more
modern setting where to stay authentic
is to threaten attachment and so we give
up her authenticity and then we wonder
who the hell you are and whose life is
this and who's experiencing all this and
this life doesn't you know and Who am I
really
and so that's where the reconnection has
to happen that's what the healing
happens is with that reconnection but
it's because of that conflict
the tragic conflict in childhood between
authenticity and attachment that most of
us face that we lose ourselves in this
connection they're good feelings there's
so many directions we can go with this
and I'm really glad you shared that
because I had an enormous that
observation has had an enormous impact
on some of my close friends and
something I was only exposed to really
today because our mutual friend Vicky
recommended that I asked you to expand
on it what I'd love to return to if we
can can I say something
yeah of course sorry in this building
there's a picture of Elvis Presley yes
so the song of his that I play at my
retreats or and my the events all the
time it's called anyway you'll love me
remember how it goes I don't I could
actually play it for you but it goes
anywhere you love me that's the way I'll
be in your hands my heart is clay I'll
be strong as a mountain or weak as a
willow tree I'll be powerful I'll be
like a little baby anyway you want me
that's how I will be now that's
considered a love song it isn't it's a
lack of love song hmm it's a song that
says chest attached to me I'll give up
anything about myself just accept me the
way you want me to be so it's a saddest
song and when you hear him sing it this
deep sadness in it
and some of the power of presley
actually came from his own suffering
he wasn't here singing a song he was
actually
infusing it with all the emotions of
laughs so even though it's presented
like a love song it's actually a song
about the loss of love and that's the
situation of the infant who says just
love me I'll be anything you want me to
be and that's the that's the tragic
conflict there's an attachment and
authenticity yeah so this ties into
exactly where I was going yeah which is
related to your pre and post work with
psychedelics yeah and for people who are
watching this or listening to it I'm
returning to this not because I want to
hammer home psychedelics they're not for
everyone and in my experience the vast
majority I should say in my observation
the vast majority of psychedelic use is
very responsible and and I would not
recommend because you it can it can
certainly cause a good amount of harm if
not done in a supervised safe fashion
but the pre and post work could apply to
many modalities I mean it it does in
this case this example they were talk
about apply to psychedelics but it could
in correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
like I could very easily apply to going
into any intense or unusual modality no
like VIP pass on a medication for
possible yeah like oh yeah this date
with destiny Tony Robbins I I mentioned
which is certainly intense and very very
different very powerful that's why I'm
coming back to this but we can discuss
it as it applies specifically to
psychedelics and even specifically to
ayahuasca that is the primary that's the
primary compound we're talking about
which is really just for people who are
wondering it's one of the reasons
ayahuasca is really tricky is that it is
unlike say I'm gonna get off the topic
for a second but it's still on topic
it's not quite like mushrooms and what
people consider the primary psychoactive
molecule of psilocybin
it's a bit different it's more of an
old-fashioned it's like if you go to a
bar and you order vodka and soda pretty
much everywhere you go
vodka soda yeah very similar assuming
the pour is the same yeah
ayahuasca is more like an old-fashioned
there are a few ingredients that are
almost always there so if you go to
let's say I want to say God bow or other
parts of Peru it's going to be mostly
the ayahuasca vine plus plant called
Czech koruna yeah or a psychotria
viridis which is a DMT I think I suppose
it must be nn DMT campaign containing
plant which is made orally active
through the MA
o inhibitors monoamine oxidase
inhibitors in the vine how they figured
that out is a whole separate story which
is kind of wild the plants told them is
the short version
I know although I have a science
scientific friend who gave me a starting
this simple explanation which oh well
it's essentially the rest in mind when I
was improved they also told me the
plants told us which on some level I
accept but but I just want to say
something here because we're talking in
an extended way about the psychedelics I
don't create the impression that this is
most of my life or work it isn't I do
this stuff one or two or three weeks a
year so it's not like the major part of
what I do but it is a very interesting
part because it illuminates everything
else that I do in a sense that it goes
very deep now
this scientific friend when the science
friend of mine says actually they were
let's say using the ayahuasca and
boiling it up because IOSCO itself the
vine has some secretary profits on its
own without the chacruna
yeah very strong auditory yeah yeah so
then what happens is some Leafs of sugar
gonna fall into it mmm inevitably over
the years that's gonna happen or they
say oh well this combination is even
more powerful yeah so then it need not
be as esoteric as it could have been a
rather simple discovery you know so who
knows what the real story is but in any
case the preparation and the processing
yeah so and I'm just gonna add welcome
to that which is that is one combination
you then also have
in certain regions of and it's found in
other places outside of Peru yes most
certainly in the largest ayahuasca as
sacrament based churches are actually
out of Brazil yeah
but the it can also be ayahuasca vine
plus yeah hay which is a different plant
I'm also DMT containing but a a for some
people a substantially different
experience yeah and then the only reason
I'm mentioning this is so that people
are aware of why I am particularly
concerned when people are cavalier about
hey my friends ordering some ayahuasca
from Hawaii and we're gonna put it in a
slow cooker and have it at his house
this weekend I'm like bad bad idea
many many centers even well-intentioned
centers in in bid who will also put
other things in the brew because they
think that foreigners want more of X so
the coca leaves they'll put self think
cocaine coca leaves they'll put PO way
which is even doctora which is even
scarier in some respects coca not that
scary so just be aware that when you say
ayahuasca not you but when people think
ayahuasca is not a standardized rose
that you were getting and recently I was
at a retreat in Costa Rica where really
four different nine state ceremonies in
each time with a different concoction Oh
God so one night with the Peruvian she
people tradition preparation one night
with the yah-hey from Colombia and you
know it's who prepares it how much they
bullet for what combination what
intention and so on so that's by and
large true that that and really the
people I worked with they you know this
is always not that it's always the same
drink every night but it's pretty much
the same preparation same preparation
yeah yeah and so I took us down a little
rabbit hole but the the question I have
is with all of your clinical experience
in recognizing that this is a therapy
but it's an adjunct therapy it's not
used in isolation yeah and you've
through trial and error and design come
to a place now where you have maybe
certain best practice
is or approaches to the pre pre and post
work mm-hmm could you tell us about
either or both of those and you know
ideally maybe exercises or questions
people could think about on their own I
know it's it's hard to recommend that in
isolation perhaps but I'd love to hear
any any details that you're willing to
share about the pre and post-show
because it's so so important I just it's
hard to for me at least in my limited
experience even to overemphasize well
with Iowa so specifically which is not
dealing them with the LD I work with but
with that specifically there's a
physical preparation for example no
caffeine for a period of time no red
meat cutting down on salt excluding
dairy products so there's a physical
preparation just to cleanse the body and
and to make it more receptive to the
ayahuasca from the emotional and
psychological point of view you want
somebody to really fund an intention
what I actually I want are this
experience because intention is
everything so it's not like I'm gonna
take the stuff and let's see what
happens why am I here for why am i
coming what is my intention and going
there what do I want to find out what
issues am i working with
so intention setting and and and really
considering what is my purpose in
undertaking this this experience when
people arrive we don't just plunge into
ceremony in my Iowa's career treats we
have a day and a half of group
preparation so everybody articulates
their intention why they're there and we
deeply explore for that intention arised
a role sorry and what in their lives
brought them to this point and what
issues they need to deal with and my way
of working is to get people very deeply
to their core issues which they may not
be even aware of but again through this
process I called compassionate inquiry
and this is true whether I'm working
with plants or not they get to to see
what it is that they're
seeking and work what are they seeking
they're seeking themselves they're
seeing the connection ultimately but
there's steps that you go through and
then we help them to set a specific
intention for that first ceremony and
the specific intention is what do I want
to learn tonight not just what I want to
learn in general but what I've learned
tonight some people want to learn about
tell me about my fear teach me about my
pain show me what love is
show me what courage is show me what my
strength is see it's not that the Iowas
comes with an agenda it works through
you and it manifests What's in you so
that your intention the more specific it
is to you where you are in life at that
moment the more effective it's going to
be and then the shamans work with you
during the ceremony and and they chant
to you based on what they're picking up
from you at that moment they work with
you energetically sometimes they work
hands-on as well and you both have your
own experience and you share the group
energy and then people go to sleep and
the next day and then the following day
we then process or what happened to you
what do what visions came to you now
some people hold of visions some people
with more prosaic Minds like an evil and
all the ever get visions yeah I did
originally get visions but it's been
years since I've seen anything
some people have bodily experiences some
people have go to him in intense
emotional states which in my view are
always memories of maybe forgotten
memories but indwelling memories of very
early experiences intense some people
have beautiful entities coming and
teaching them you know Jaguars and
anacondas or various angelic entities
I've never been blessed with that and
I used to get frustrated but actually
whatever experience you have that's the
experience you need to have and and for
me it's not about the visions or
anything it's about what is the teaching
and the teaching is always there and the
purpose of the processing is to help you
find the teaching that was imparted to
you by whatever experience you had not
about comparing your experience to the
night before or two nights before or two
the experience of other people
it's your specific experience what does
it mean in your life so this is and now
post retreat then again whether you do a
program like Vipassana would you do the
Landmark Forum or ready to do a hoffman
process already do any kind of
transformational work or a meditation
retreat if you don't integrate what
you've learned into your life and you
build up some practice around it it's
gonna become a memory a nice memory at
best right yeah straight back into
making hyper critical decisions
intensively yeah 12 hours later also
absolutely very destructive absolutely
so the more integration we can then and
and in and the general in the
psychedelic work this no question of
integration is becoming more and more
recognized and and and a more a more
practiced so integration means keeping
in touch with people that can help you
stay on track keeping in touch with the
group that you share the experience with
putting some practice into your life
such as journaling meditation yoga
perhaps you're going to return and do
some more plant work or perhaps you
won't that's entirely up to you there's
no prescription to be made there but the
point is to go from experience that is
discrete and time limited to some kind
of integration that is that happens over
time how do you format that that
integration are you interacting with the
people on your retreat once a week for
four weeks or you have two sessions in
following week
what is the actual format well that's
evolving and that's different for
different people but
in general I would say that if you can
talk to somebody regularly over time and
if you can maintain your contact with
the group so they're like a Facebook
group Facebook group where people share
experiences if you take on certain
practices and you do them together or at
least you do them simultaneously and
then you talk share about practices
these are all forms of integration which
and we've mentioned this a few times
applies to more than just the modality
of using plant medicine absolutely so
after this that sound like broken record
but this is very recent
after going to this trendy Robbins event
with a number of people including we
have photo online so I think he's fine
with me saying it Joe Gebbia co-founder
of Airbnb Marc Benioff the CEO of
Salesforce was sitting right behind me
mmm he wasn't part of the group but he's
a friend at least an acquaintance
getting to know each other in any case
we kept a group text great going
afterwards to hold each other
accountable and also to set follow-up
group calls right and so on a number of
things I'd really like to underscore
because you mentioned them and and I'd
like to reiterate their importance and
also how they transcend the present work
yeah the psychedelics the first is you
mentioned intentions and I'll just I'll
just share my experience and also a
number of recommendations that helped me
tremendously
yeah with samisen work but then life
which is you set a clear intention but
the clear intention is not the same as
an expectation that's right and if you
go in to and you have an expectation you
can't let go of that's right you end up
many people end up trying to
white-knuckle the experience and that's
true in general in life and it's very
true for a plant experiences yeah so if
you get there that this is gonna happen
that's good this should happen and some
people sit there the whole night
resisting their experience because this
it doesn't meet their expectations right
so there's there's a there's a card it's
a little card that I was given as a gift
which I didn't come to appreciate fully
until maybe a year to I've been carrying
it a long time
and it's it was given to me by an
ex-girlfriend it's and it says the tax
the task which hinders your task is your
task and so you mentioned a few things
and you said well that is the work for
that night and I've come to know a few
people I respect as I hesitate to use
the word but they're because they're
really only two or three people I've
personally met I would feel comfortable
calling a shaman and they all have
minimum 10-15 years experience in a
traditional apprenticeship setting and
by the way that means deep personal work
very that means sitting in a jungle by
yourself being bitten by mosquitoes
doing that means drinking various plants
tobacco and other plants not beyond
Iowa's rent and really preparing I know
somebody on that path right now let me
tell you very deep its deep committed
work it's not very faint over here even
I would never do it yeah it's very
intense a very very intense and I mean
there are people do 15 months of
isolation dieting various plants no sex
an assault a fork in the road man you
know you know this really won't get into
right now and what's with they've
they've shared a few examples with me of
say I I've never well that's not true
but I I have always in the past shied
away from large groups that's why I was
taken aback with mentioning 50 people
but it is it seems very common in any
group especially larger groups and this
is true in psychedelics or at the pass
on of retreats they actually the
nickname for it that was given at the
the 10-day silent retreat I did it's
spirit rock was the Vipassana Vendetta
where you decide that someone who's
sitting close to you is coughing too
loudly clears their throat too often or
whatever and it starts to you start to
perseverate and think about it
incessantly and maybe get angry about it
and since they don't watch any own
reaction instead of watching your
reaction and you know that they're the
example that was given to me by this
this this particular I'm just going to
say ayahuasca door to simplify things
ayahuasca Doyle some
works with iOS Conn was told me about
this this this Westerner came down I
guess guess they're kind of Westerners -
they're just south of the border so
northern American who came down and was
furious that someone in the group
wouldn't shut up with their screaming he
was just furious about this and there
are a number of ways an organizer can
handle that but he took the guy outside
and he said that person is your work
tonight absolutely and if you think
about that reframe and how to view
something that perhaps historically you
would respond to as a problem or an
annoyance or offensive to view that and
there's certain times where you have to
fight and stand up for yourself I'm not
saying you shouldn't but I think that in
my case and in the cases of many folks
we fight too often we were ourselves out
we get upset too often how can you view
that as a gift how can you view that as
your work
look can I again give you a quote yes
please which I love it's one of my from
one of my favorite teachers and his name
is aah illness and he says your
conflicts all the difficult things
they're problematic situations in your
life are not chance or haphazard they're
actually yours they're specifically
yours designed specifically for you by a
part of you that loves you more than
anything else the part of you that loves
you more than anything else has created
roadblocks to lead you to yourself
you're not going you're not going to go
in the right direction unless there's
something freakin on the side saying
telling you look here this way that part
is you love you so much that part of you
loves you so much that it doesn't want
you to lose the chance it will go to
extreme measures to wake you up it will
make you suffer greatly if you don't
listen what else can it do that's its
purpose and I found this to be true of
physical illness and mental problems and
everything you got to see what is the
teaching here so we can look at all
these things as problems to get rid of
which is what the personality wants to
do or we can look at them as learning
opportunities which is what your true
self wants to do now two things one is
you talked about intention in life
my wife and I had a holiday recently in
Costa Rica a party was a working holiday
but partly it was just a holiday
traditionally we've had terrible times
doing holidays party because my book
haul is them and once they go into a
holiday I just collapsed and know my
wife is dragging a corpse around you
know because I'm a workaholic you know
and I hadn't clear space so so this time
we actually want to do a holiday with
intention this is nothing but
psychedelics just to do it that we set
an intention what is it our intention
and if we have an intention I've learned
from a couple of very wife's teachers
what structures we want to set up to
support our intention and how are we
gonna handle when there's kind of
disagreement or conflict with a
beautiful holiday because it was the
first intentional holiday that we've had
so that intention in life in general is
absolutely essential like every morning
what is my actual intention I want to do
a bit of an exercise sure okay and then
you know if you don't like it just tell
me when was the last this is something I
do in my groups or when I speak or in a
song when I teach so yes I ask people to
tell me some recent episode whenever
said with somebody with their lives and
something that they were open to sharing
so it doesn't have anything sordid or
thing but just sending out whether it's
your spouse partner the bus driver I
don't care sure a friend okay so I you
think about anything okay I can share
anything just where you're upset with
somebody okay yes okay so what happened
describe it what happened yeah alright
there were a number of issues in my home
broken aspects of the home things that
were falling apart or needed to be fixed
physically physically okay yeah right
and I had hired someone to do these
things right while I was gone
okay and I came back and none of them
were fixed okay and your emotional
reaction was anger rage anger okay
anything else besides anger mmm I think
they're close cousins frustrate
personal frustration his anger yeah yep
was disappointed disappointed his
sadness yeah it's a different feeling
so it's disappointed myself also because
I started to look at how maybe well
disappointed is not so much an emotion
as a state of mind and asking what the
emotions were I'm like what's inside
disappointment something didn't happen I
wanted to happen how do I feel there's
no sadness there sure yeah there's
sadness I'm not talking into it I'm just
asking well I suppose um I might be
confusing State of Mind and states of
mind and emotions I'm not sure I look at
the raw emotion yeah sadness
so there's anger and sadness those are
the emotions let's let's go with that
okay so I'm gonna ask you a silly
question
what were you said in angry about well I
suppose the answer which is not the
right answer I'm expecting was as angry
that someone had made commitments to me
and not fulfilled those commitments
okay what that's what happened they've
made the commitment but that doesn't
tell me what you're sad or angry well
what does that mean that they didn't
fulfill their commitments uh meant that
they didn't care about me they didn't
say I have that they respect me so they
didn't care about you didn't respect you
what kind of person doesn't get cared or
respected mmm-hmm I might need a
lifeline here I don't know someone who
doesn't deserve to be cared for a
respected exactly somebody unworthy
right sure well respect then and and
care okay know if two other people here
which they usually are when I do this
exercise I would ask them okay we just
listened to him tell us about this
experience are there other reasons why
this other person might not have done
the work that has nothing to do with him
or her not caring about him or not
respecting him so what are the reasons
might there be a million-in-one format
name one yep the
he could have he could be in the
hospital her cared one could have been
in a car accident
exactly he had a flight delaying got
caught on Puerto Rico during a hurricane
him yeah he's got ADHD yeah he and he
can't follow through he's under stress
and he couldn't write okay okay you know
the email that I was supposed to send is
sitting in drafts and I thought I'd sent
it but in fact you never received it I
mean okay and any number of
possibilities yep no of all the
possibilities that you've just outlined
including that he they don't care about
you or respect you which is the worst
one the one I immediately defaulted to
right well I mean the worst no but
internally yeah internally the worst
assumption that's the one that I
immediately made exactly so let's notice
something hey you I should say we
because we're all like this we don't
respond to what happens we respond to
our perception of what happens right
okay that's what the Buddha said it's
with our minds who create the world so
that if you'd found that ADHD or he was
stressed or you know you might have been
sad for him boy would not have been
angry and you will not have been sad
okay you might you know so first of all
we don't respond to what happens we
respond to our perception of what
happens to our interpretation of times
number one number two of all the
possible interpretations we choose the
worst one yep
number two thirdly what I just said
isn't true we didn't choose it it's not
like you went through all these
possibilities option no he doesn't care
about me he doesn't respect me you
didn't do that your brain jump there
automatically right my question is why
yep now here's the learning first time
in your life that you felt hurt and
angry that you when you perceive
somebody didn't care about you or didn't
respect you where is it happening before
this is where the exercise might might
might go sideways I'm gonna hit pause on
that I think that's probably for more of
a conversation over wine but you
probably agreed it's not the first time
it's not the first time very good and
most people I talk to
it goes back way back yeah this goes way
back and into childhood mmm
okay and that's what trauma is we don't
respond to the present moment we respond
to the past no but along the lines of
our discussion it's a beautiful learning
opportunity
now you get to know now what if you
assume for a moment that you're the most
lovable most worthy of care most worthy
of respect person in the history of the
universe and this guy doesn't do your
own what's your response any number of
the other options which does not trigger
their an intense negative emotional
stare so there's other options who
trigger that so something in use I would
argue still believes that you're not
worthy of care and respect and that's
what gets triggered so who's the one
that doesn't care about you and who's
the one that doesn't think you really
respect you ya know that's a learning
notice and this is exactly what you're
talking about you're saying how these
difficult things how these problems are
always teaching opportunities and that's
the beauty of healing is that when you
reframe things and you and you actually
see the source within ourselves all of a
sudden that's liberating because guess
what if you're feeling that way because
this guy did this or didn't do that that
makes you a victim yep
but if you see that you're the source ya
know you're powerful yeah you're
empowered they're empowered as Isis you
this is something that a friend of mine
here in Austin Robert Rodriguez recently
said to me in a very similar way I mean
it was a completely different context he
was actually telling a story about
someone else who was constantly blaming
people for everything in the film world
mm-hmm and he said if you are the victim
and you're and it's everyone else's
fault you were powerless mm-hmm and he
said we keep in mind every time you're
pointing a finger at someone and I had
never heard this I I know it now after
the fact that that there are other
people who have said this but he said
every time you're pointing a finger at
someone keep in mind that there are
three fingers pointing back at you
exactly and I thought about that I Wow
yeah this is just a good
that's very sentence to keep in mind no
you know this is a recording studio
sometime was it this the yeah they do
recordings they did they record in the
past oh just I just the the Johnny Cash
every record here but you know I don't
know if Johnny Cash's over here its pop
I would say it's possible because it's
been around for a long time the reason I
ask is because he's got a song that I
play at all my events it's gonna in your
mind it's called this is it all goes
done in your mind it's on the soundtrack
of dead man walking and I think he would
himself it all goes done in your mind
and it goes one foot in the fire one
foot on Jacob's Ladder another than the
fire it all goes down in your mind so
whether you going to hell or I tell you
on the way to heaven it all happens up
here which is such a powerful teaching
because this is what we can work on you
know if we've if we're victims of the
world ramana maharshi was a great Indian
guru he said something like if your foot
hurts when you walk outside you can do
two things one is the rap the whole
world in burlap or you can get a pair of
shoes you can see yourself as the victim
of the world and trying to change the
world so that you'd they won't hurt you
anymore or you can actually empower
yourself yeah and that's what the
healing is all about well I will say the
reason I wanted to have you on now is
because I've been so focused on trying
to navigate these things myself over the
last several years but most intensely
over the last several months mm-hmm and
I wanted to be ready to have this
conversation with you and and how you
doing so far I'm great I'm great I'm
great I'm doing very well
I think I'm the the sameness and
arguably in the best place I've been
maybe ever so I feel that's why very
good that's a good which means that that
healing just is just available it's just
possible yeah you know I I got an email
a few months ago
a woman called Betty Nagar in the
Hermann Goering was the chief of the
Luftwaffe under her god that's right
types wondering right into that name
yeah and and he was head of the Gestapo
just a an opiate addict by the way and
in a very clever very ruthless man his
great niece sent me an e-mail a few
months ago to thank me for my work and
she's been through her own process
imagine the Karma she was carrying yeah
and all the healing she has had to do so
there was her grant her great-uncle
trying to kill me and my people and
there's the great niece making contact
with me and to me just in your example
and my example in the example of so many
people I know it's not like I'm a big
piece of cake you know it's gonna
continue as long as I live but I
experienced internally the goodness and
the healing that's available to us and I
didn't used to and I and I used to think
I could help you everybody but but that
I was beyond hearing myself that was my
core belief you know well let's play my
corporate for the last ten years okay
it's just ain't true and anybody
listening I just want to know it doesn't
matter what state of mind you and
doesn't matter what you're experiencing
it's human it it is transmuted all it is
transformable because that too soft that
you got disconnected from it's still
available to you so it's not a question
of just talking about what happened in
the past it's a question of how do we
connect to ourselves and what you're
describing about your own state if I can
put it in one sentence you'd probably
agree with me that you probably much
more connected to yourself than used to
be 100 percent yeah that's the s and
that's the SP requisite I mean that's
that's why I feel the way I described
exactly gabor I really want to encourage
people to learn more about you and your
work and there's there's certainly a
number of places they could start where
would you suggest people dig more deeply
is there
particular book of your books you would
suggest they start with is there a
particular social media handle where
they can pay attention and learn various
announcements and see what you share of
your work and others
well thanks for asking the simplest
thing is my website
www.marykay.co.uk/awilliam visit about
my work that's been seen 12 million
times now so there's all kinds of ways
to discover me on Facebook on YouTube at
my website and I would also really hope
that people check out my books of which
I've written for the first one the
American title is scattered and it's
about ADHD and I wrote it after my own
diagnosis and pretty much what I've said
earlier that I don't see it as an
inherited disease I do see it as a
response to family multi-generational
and social stress in sensitive children
people say you're blaming the parents
I'm not blaming the parents I don't
blame myself but I know how stressed my
family was when I was a workaholic
doctor and so that's my first book and
when you say well why are we looking at
the percentage of kids with ADHD going
up so fast it's not because of any
genetic problem genes don't change in a
population over five or ten years it's a
social problem there's much more stress
in the culture now there's much less
connection in the culture now and less
connected people are and the more stress
there is the more pressure there is on
sensitive kids
so that's scattered another parenting
book of mine is the work of a brilliant
psychologist friend of mine Gordon
Neufeld
dr. Neufeld who is the world's leading
development psychologist as far as I'm
personally concerned
say that advisedly and the book is
called hold on to your kids why parents
need to matter more than peers that's
been published in over 20 languages now
and it's about the fact that since
kidneys attachment the attachment need
is the primary drive that we have and
we've talked about that it's like a
duckling when the duckling hatches from
the egg the duckling would prefer to
attach an imprint on the mother duck but
what will he do if the mother duck is
not around
he'll imprint on a toy or a dog or a
horse our kids because the parents are
too distracted and stressed in our
society and are not aren't so much
anymore physically as during human
evolution now find themselves in the
company of other kids guess what they
imprint on their peer group and now you
have immature creatures influencing each
other
immoderately and this happens through
the social media
it happens in personal contact and as
that happens the parents get pushed into
the background they get normal
frustrated not they get more
authoritarian or they just give up and
kids therefore don't grow up they don't
mature and they develop all kinds of
problems not because the parents don't
love them but because simply because in
this culture the connection between kids
and parents have been really disturbed
and how do we store that connection is
the subject of hold on to your kids so
three of my books are what on my own
this one I wrote with Gordon my next
book which is on a mind-body unity and
health and illness and that's a
conversation you know I could have
another time but again where I show that
cancer autoimmune disease ALS multiple
sclerosis Parkinson's colitis Crohn's
disease chronic fatigue fibromyalgia are
not accidental and separate physical
events they had to do with the
scientifically proven fact that mind and
body can't be separated and when things
happen emotionally there will also
happen physiologically in fact it can't
be any other way and that the emotional
system in our brains in our bodies an
important parcel of the same system that
also governs the immunity no joke
neurological response and hormonal
response and therefore when our life
length patterns of emotional repression
when people have to suppress themselves
you know what the main
their attachments that will have a
negative impact on their immune system
and their hormonal apparatus and the
nervous systems as well and that book is
called when the body says no exploring
the stress disease connection and that's
been published by over in over 20
countries internationally as well
including in the u.s. my final and to my
mind my favorite book is the most recent
in the realm of hungry ghosts close
encounters with addiction which explores
the diction not from the point of view
of disease model or a choice model but
how it is a response to a childhood loss
stress and trauma and how to address
that and also how to deal with like if
you look at the United States right now
you know what the facts are the most
common cause of death under the age of
50 is not overdose and in the US every
three weeks you have the equivalent of a
911 in turn every three weeks the 911 in
terms of the number of people dying
aware is the public outcry where is the
resources where is the political will
where is the mobilization of the media
and and all the public health energies
compared to what happened after 9/11 and
we have Ennis every three weeks and why
because the treatment profession the
medical profession and politicians and
the legal profession does not understand
trauma and its relationship to addiction
the average medical student doesn't even
hear the word trauma in four years of
education doesn't mean hear the word let
alone get a lecture on it let her go get
a course about it the stuff I told you
about brain development is still not
taught in most medical schools so we
have this response to addiction which is
just dealing with the effects the
behaviors controlling the the
manifestations and not dealing with the
causative factors that's why people
don't get better and if you look at why
right now it's because social stress is
increased economic insecurity is
increased
you don't look at where do the opiate
overdose happens more it's where areas
where there's despondency and despair
totally and so that's the book in the
realm of hungry ghosts other than that
lots of my talks are on YouTube but I
think the best hub to check all the
stuff out is my website and I hope to
generate a podcast regular podcast
fairly soon if the people are on weekend
too
I am strong enough and and organized me
well enough to do it there'll be a
podcast and I hope that'll be up soon
but knowing myself I don't wanna make
any promises
but that'll certainly be listed at my
website if it happens and could you give
your website URL one more time
okay dr. Gabbe on that day and dr.
Garber Mata calm and to everybody
listening and watching there's the
camera
I will also put that in the show notes
so for everyone everything we've
discussed the books the resources
organizations everything including your
website which will be at the very top
will be listed in the show notes which
you can find at IMTA blog forward slash
podcast and it'll be right at the top so
all that will be very easy to find just
in closing and we may very well end up
doing around to at some point it
wouldn't surprise me even if it's
off-camera certainly would like I spend
more time together
do you have any final closing words or a
request or suggestion to the audience
anything for people listening that you
would like them to consider after they
finish this interview yeah okay I hope
people bulla citizen to you in a very
personal sense not just as a an
interesting experience but it's possibly
pertaining to themselves and that the
discussion with you will help people
look at themselves in maybe a new way
with what I call compassionate inquiry
so rather than self judgment about stuff
that went wrong or they did it to
themselves or others they get curious
what made me do that they get curious
compassionately because we were all born
innocent and we're all born just wanted
to be loving and loved and then
something happens and then is it's a
hard road back but I hope that this
conversation helps people reconnect with
that path or can or encourage them to
continue on it
and then secondly not to see it as an
individual issue it's a social issue we
live in a society that really does
disconnect people and so it's not just
an individual problem or an individual
family problem its multi-generational we
never even talked about the mochila
multi-generational nature of trauma what
it is we pass this on from one
generation to the next not because we
intend to but because we can't help it
so it needs to be looked at in deep over
the generations and broadly as the
function of a whole society now let me
give you one quick example if I may a
study last year showed that American
black women the more experienced the
races and they have the greater the risk
of asthma and what does that tell us
what a gift we give people to to control
their asthma we give them inhalers that
contain a copy of adrenaline and a copy
of cortisol the stress hormones in other
words asthma as Evan who would stress
I'm not going to the scientific details
now it could but it won't but it shows
this question is the asthma of an
American black woman an individual
disease was it a dysfunction of entire
society and obviously it's the latter so
that the Buddha said that without the
many that cannot be the one without the
one that cannot be the many and he
talked about the interconnected core
rising of phenomena so we are social
creatures our brains are wired together
dr. dan Siegel talks about interpersonal
neurobiology we're not isolated
creatures so what have you dealing with
you have to look at not just the
individual internal environment but also
the broader social and cultural
environment of which your one particular
manifestation and as our mutual friend
drew polish so firm P wants we need to
change the conversation around these
issues particular for example on
addiction from a blaming and shaming and
ostracizing and just medical model
perspective to one that takes into
account trauma and social issues and
which brings compassion into it and that
must be the same for all mental health
issues as well and whatever we look at
we have to look at both the individual
and the broader context
thank you for that and you mentioned how
we all begin loving and wanting to be
loved or needing love and then something
happens and it's a hard road back and
what I'd like to add to that is it's a
hard road back but it's a worthwhile
road back and it is possible to find
your way back if you had told me that a
year ago I would have completely
dismissed it but I'm in a different
place now and I would just like to thank
you for helping people to navigate that
and it's very meaningful work that you
do thank you thank you for taking the
time today as well thank you and to
everybody listening and watching as I
mentioned before definitely also visit
the show notes revisit this this is not
a one and done something you listen to
and then you go on as if you never heard
it please look at the show notes look at
God boards work and you can find all
that at teamed-up log forward slash
podcast and to everybody listening I
would just say as always thank you so
much for joining